hello everyone and welcome back to the
semi-finals of the ftx crypto cup we are
back with
the other match it's yanny palmisia
versus uh wesley so and
this is the third game of their second
match if you remember from yesterday uh
wesley won the fourth game you know uh
the
the the game with all of the mosquitoes
uh and now nipple needs to
win uh today's match to bounce back and
then to force tie breaks otherwise it's
wasted so against whoever wins the other
match in the finals of the ftx crypto
cup
so this uh it's a very exciting game
and it really shows uh how nipple really
needs a win
because he really fights in this game uh
so without further ado let's check it
out and see
see what happens so nipple with the
white pieces opens with
d4 and the reason why he really needs a
win
is because he lost yesterday's match and
he already uh played two games
getting only a draw so now this is his
last game in the match uh if
if he doesn't win with the white pieces
uh because
game for wesley has the white pieces and
it's very unlikely that he will be able
to uh
win with black on demand against wesley
so here knight to f6 we have c4 e6
knight to c3 and d5 we have just a
normal
uh queen's gambit declined uh and here
nipple goes for uh
the early trade in the center c captures
on d5
knight captures and e4 we have knight
captures on c3 b
captures and now c5 so um almost a
groomfield without
the the dark square bishop being fiance
so here we have rook to b1
and bishop to e7 we have knight to f3
and
castles and now uh h4 nepo is now ready
to play h5 he's going to go for the very
early rook lift and he's going to start
an attack against wesley's king
so here b6 wesley ready to think out of
his own light square bishop
and now h5 as planned uh we have h6
preventing this pawn from advancing any
further and the bishop to d3 now so it's
a very aggressive move
but it prevents the queen from defending
the d4 pawn uh so wesley immediately
uses this to his advantage c
captures on the four c captures and now
knight the c6
now instead of knight to c6 this
position has been reached once
uh in the 2019 uh world rapid
championship uh world blitz championship
in moscow
i was played between eleven aaron and
martin bosio chichen in that game uh
which played e5 level and was able to
win that game but here like i said we
have knight to c6 now with a double
attack here
and now nepo needs the waist to move as
he already placed the bishop on d3 so
now he goes back bishop to e2 so the
queen also defends the d4 pawn
so maybe not too precise in now bishop
to b7 by wesley
uh we have rook to h3 uh he just wants
to get his uh pieces into the attack
and rook the c8 we have rook to g3
sort of a barbarian style attack and now
kink the h8 now the thread is just
bishop captures on h6 because the g pawn
is pinned
so king to h8 and now a3
we have knight to a5 now opening up the
the light square bishop also the knight
can now come to c4
uh which will be an excellent square for
the knight bishop
back to d3 by nipple now he says okay
you move the knight now my bishop can
move here and now at some point i would
like to play e5
open up my light square bishop my dark
square bishop will be also attacking the
king side
and maybe good things will happen so
here knight to c4 by wesley
and now king the f1 again going very
aggressive here
uh saying that if you go for my a pawn
uh it doesn't really matter
because if you capture with the bishop i
can simply eliminate the defender of the
bishop and if you capture with the
knight
uh just rook to a1 with a double attack
on the knight and once the knight moves
we're gonna pick up the a7 pawn
and it's just much much better for white
uh sorry
not uh like that uh we're gonna capture
uh
after the knight goes back then we're
gonna capture on a7
so instead after king to f1 we have
knight to d6
uh and now comes uh the move we've all
been waiting for and that is
d5 and this is just a all-out attacking
move
instead of this you could just play it
very safe for example with queen to e to
just add another defender here
the problem is black can just bust open
the position with f5
and after we trade let's say captures
captures now the rook is under attack
and also thus
this pawn and after you save the rook
we're gonna eliminate
one of the defenders of the d4 pawn
queen captures and now knight captures
here and the black is just better here
so instead after knight to d6 uh nipple
goes for d5
and this is just beautiful now the this
entire diagonal has opened up for his
dark square bishop and he is about to
commence an attack against wesley's king
so here we have e captures on d5 wesley
accepts one of the pawns but now bishop
to b2
attacking the g7 square so what will
wesley do now
uh well you can even pause the video for
a little bit
and try and figure out what wesley
played here because it's not
what you may first think of while
checking out the disposition so have at
it while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
not defending the g7 pawn in any way
yeah and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the pawn
the pawns in the show uh it's d captures
an e4
that's just beautiful allowing such a
move in a rapid game wesley wesley
realizes that
there is actually no danger here so nepo
captures the pawn
bishop captures on g7 it doesn't matter
if you capture with the rook you could
also capture with the rook and claim
that maybe you have some sort of
sort of a nasty discovery later on but
just bishop to f6 and you don't have any
uh discoveries here so instead we have
bishop captures this comes with
check king to h7 now defending the h
uh h6 pawn and now bishop captures an f8
uh grabbing the rook bishop captures an
f8 and now what do you play here
a lot of moves are possible but none of
them are particularly good because this
is attacked this is attacked and
there's simply not much to play you kind
of want to save the light square bishop
because
well it's just a very long attacking
piece but
if you play something like bishop to c2
knights to f5 is deadly
attacking this rook also the bishop now
gains full support across this diagonal
also you offer a queen trade also the
bishop on c2 is under attack so
this is just uh dead lost uh you have to
play something let's say you try and
save some material
uh we're gonna trade queens for example
captures captures and now we pick up the
knight
captures on f3 bishop captures and now
we're going to trade here
captures captures and let's say rook to
c7 and that's it
the the bishop and knight of course will
be will be stronger than the rook
uh so this is one way to do it uh rook
the g4 is what nepo tried he played it
right away but now
he captures on d3 and now rook to d4
uh now uh pinning this knight but also
just getting ready to win this
pawn here but now wesley plays the very
sneaky rook to c3 and rook the c3
is a move you don't want to see here
because although you can win this spawn
uh there's this uh always the very
unpleasant bishop to a6 and that's a
problem
the rook and king are now on the same
diagonal and that's just it black wins
so here instead we have queen to b2 now
attacking the rook and now
queen to c7 uh we have queen to f4
shifting the queen into the attack maybe
now you can try something if if the
knight can also get into the attack
maybe you can somehow bring this rook
into the attack
uh also it you know
things might become possible but here uh
wesley just starts eliminating all of
the attackers bishop captures an f3
g captures on f3 and now rook to c4
uh getting ready to exchange another
another attacker
we have rook to d1 and now he just
trades rook captures queen captures and
now queen to c4 hoping to trade off the
queens as well then black's position is
just winning
even though you win the pawn for example
rook captures on d3 we can just play a5
and there is no playing this
uh this is uh this is now under attack
uh you can't really
play all that much to defend it if a4
just knight b2 we're gonna go for the
double attack
and now if you want to keep on defending
this pawn then this rook will be
useless for the rest of the game so this
is not uh not possible
so after queen to c4 queen to e3 and yep
of course needs the queen and the rook
to remain in the game if he is to pose
any problems to the black king and now
knight to b5 goes after the pawn uh we
have rook captures on d3
and now bishop captures an a3 now nipple
has two connected pass pawns on the
queen side
and that's also one more thing to worry
about
uh wesley has so here king to g2
and now bishop back to c5 attacking the
queen
queen to d2 and now just knight to d4
stopping all of white's counter play
uh we rook to e3 and now a5
so not much for for nipple to do here uh
we
rook the e5 uh and now comes f6
uh chasing the rogue back also the
bishop covers the e7 square
so here we have rook to e4 but now f5
further attacking
the rook we have rooked the e8 uh and
here uh nepo is in a really really bad
position
he's one of those players that can uh
you know get out of any position but
this one might be a bit too much so here
queen to f7 was played now just chasing
back the rook
you could also play something active
like queen to c2 but
then you might run into some rook to h8
ideas and you don't want to calculate
this with little time on the clock of
course you know from experience that
this is enough to maybe get a draw but
after let's say h6
could be it could be ugly you know just
uh just to waste time so
unnecessarily so instead after rook to
e8 we have queen to f7 stopping all of
white's counterplay
and now we have queen to e1 defending
the rook here but now
queen to g7 check king to h1 and now
knight captures on f3 attacking the
queen here so queen to d1
attacking the knight but here uh wesley
just played queen to f7 and he was in
this position on move 40
uh that yanni palmicious resigned to the
game and it is wesley show who will face
the winner of the match magnus carlsen
versus temura java
uh to see who will win the entire ftx
crypto cup
so here you resign as uh well your rook
is under attack you can either trade
this which is just completely lost or
you could play some like
there's really no good square for the
rook you have to move it somewhere
but there really isn't any uh all of
these squares are covered as you can see
you you can you can place the e2 but e2
is such a funny square
because you immediately get checkmated
queen captures with check
king to g2 now we're going to deliver
this check and after the king moves one
more time queen h3
will be checkmate so after queen to f7
nepal resigned and
wesley is off to the finals so whoever
wins will have
will have an incredible opponent because
i don't think wesley lost
a single game in this event so far let
me just check real quickly
uh wesley where are you wesley
yeah not a single loss in this game so
out of the uh out of the seven games
against maximum and out of these
seven game against nipple uh he did not
lose a single game so that's
the kind of uh player wesley is and uh
well who
whoever wins the the other match will be
will be definitely up against the
monster
uh so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to thank uh
jonathan linder
david brigging mb ride rodrigo river
river dinera
and suresh kota for contribution to my
channel uh thank you a lot to really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this uh very
nice event
so thank y'all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your weekend